so we talked about like museums and like
you know like not really like vibing
with art exhibitions and stuff like that
how do you guys feel about guided tours
I hate them hate them
something we all agree about finally
unless the tour guide is an absolute
goat and loves his job and is like super
knowledgeable and super like upbeat like
I have seen some tour guides who you're
like okay damn I want to be on this tour
but like most of them are just hey this
happens to be a really historical area
with a lot of stuff going on we paid
some guy who's kinda into it like he
doesn't really care yeah and he's just
following let's just let's just recite a
script yeah you know like London stuff
the most interesting people uh to ask
about London and local London like
traditions or places just normally like
cab drivers yeah they know London show
well and they're so passionate about it
yeah I got on the cab one time and the
guy just happened to be a certified tour
guide in London and he gave me like so
many any good recommendations of pubs
and places to go eat for like really
good stuff that I never knew even when I
was living there right and that was way
better than going on some guided tour
that you pay out of the ass for where
some guy really uninspiredly talked
about talks about London right like I
feel that it's such a it's such a mixed
bag where it's just not worth it a lot
of the time and also [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna
walk around for two hours on some guided
tour I just want to do my own thing yeah
yeah oh that's the thing like I I get
why guidance
because like I get I get why guided
tours exist right because you know for a
lot of people who aren't used to
traveling and you know maybe a little
bit worried about you know potentially
going to some place that's a little like
uh or you know potentially scared to
have it not as good as an experience
right it's good for school yeah and it's
good for school kids yeah but like but
then I I also think that's what put me
off tour guides because yeah every time
we went on a tour guide school trip it
was the most boring ass [ __ ] thing of
all time
[ __ ] school trips of coal mines yeah
so much yeah because Wales you had a
massive cold boom uh in like I think
like the 50s 60s I think there's tons of
coal mines in Wales I remember I went to
one which was uh
processing that right okay you're like
why did we take the kids today
it's a part of Welsh history and now
these kids in Minecraft are they
yearning for the minds right so yeah we
went to these mines right and uh they
would literally just go into the mine
like straight up go into it they'd be
like this is where they would mind the
cold yeah would you say would you say
that was the worst guided tour that you
ever went on because the worst one for
me was uh we got taken to a sewage
Plantation
uh when we were like I think like eighth
grade uh because there was one right
near our high school
um okay and uh they were like yeah it's
just like it's like 10 minutes a few
things in my high school I don't think
they filmed it's like 15 minutes by bus
so uh let's go check out how uh your
your [ __ ] is uh processed and we went
there and a it was boring as [ __ ] and B
smelled like [ __ ] two kids fainted
because of how bad it smelled and I'm
just like and I'm just like teacher why
did you this is like a punishment this
is not why not learning anything other
than the fact that yes indeed poop does
smell very bad you smell bad who smell
bad I knew that yeah that was my father
stinky oh oh stinky what pass out why
did they take you to a sewage plant I I
don't know because I I guess like the
teacher was like let's find out how uh
you know this kind of uh you know these
kinds of Dirty Jobs exist and people
need to you know do this kind of thing
and it's it's good for the environment
it's good for the oceans and stuff like
that so let's let's find out have you
ever wondered how what happens after you
flush your toilet and and all the kids
are like no actually uh I'm sure it goes
to some [ __ ] Plantation but uh do I
care about how it's processed not really
I'd rather do a sewage tour plan uh than
do some kind of over tourist thing like
do a tour of Venice or something yeah
yeah that's too bad I think I did that
one time my parents I remember thinking
like oh it's so boring so boring yeah
yeah I I kind of like coming to this
realization as an adult because for the
longest time I just thought I don't like
history I'm I'm just not a history I
love history yeah I I'm just gonna
realization that no history if history
[ __ ] slaps history is like so
interesting but I just thought he was so
boring as a kid because it was taught to
me in the most like boring ass man I'm
exactly the same I I can I just like I
was just like damn I hated history class
but as an adult when you get to pick and
choose what history you want to die you
know do a full dive into it's
fascinating as [ __ ] yeah I think you
should I think as a kid I was just
always like this is insane like 50 years
ago it's like a totally different place
yeah that's so cool yeah but like in
different periods of time it's
essentially just a different Human
Experience all together I'm sure that's
what I like I'm sure a little bit of
that I felt as well as a student but it
was just set again it was just taught to
me in such an asinine way where it's
just like I feel like I'm just like
listening to someone recite the
dictionary to me it's just like it's not
fun like like even we had like some
school trips where we went to uh you
know some famous places where
um it's like some famous battles
happened in like the history of England
and I I look back at these battles I'm
like these this is like some [ __ ]
Game of Thrones this kind of [ __ ] right
it's it's it's actually like insane the
[ __ ] that was going on but I remember
going to the school trip as a kid for
like the Battle of Hastings right
no we did we went to
went to the the tapestry in France I
think right you know where they have the
they are tapestry the really wrong thing
about the battle Yeah Hastings are 1066
right 10-16 yeah
um and uh yeah I mean if you know it was
a very famous historic battle that you
know changed the time in the UK yeah
change the tide of like British like
English History and everything like that
um and you know we went to like some of
the fields where the battles took place
and I remember as a kid they just I just
found it's I just find it so hard to
immerse myself in what someone's telling
me when someone's like just like citing
or facts in the most monotone way yeah
because they were just like and this is
where the battle took place where all of
these people died and everything like
that and I'm just like it's a [ __ ]
field why are we here
it's a field I remember because
obviously we have a ton of castles in
Wales yeah we did some school trips to
some castles and there was like uh you
could do like a peasant experience or
something
we went into like um
we had to yeah do a bunch of things like
the average peasant would do right yeah
and we would eat what they would eat and
of course bread and soup yeah it was
just that sounds interesting though yeah
yeah but as a kid you're like as a kid
it was kind of cool but as an adult I'm
like nice
you scammed me no it was cool I tell a
lot I think at the time I actually
really enjoyed that stuff more because
like they yeah you know I thought that
was really cool as a kid because they
would actually make you get involved in
the history like it wasn't like we would
just tell you and this is what they ate
it was like Hey kids where where these
because we would dress up as well like
The Peasants
um yeah like that's at least that at
least there's like an interactive
elements there yeah and then we would
like they never let us do anything cool
even if it is questionable
I just have this image of like the
adults being and then the child dressed
up as the peasant
they wouldn't say that but that's now
what I'm remembering it being uh because
you know it was it was like they would
make yeah we would have to like I
remember we would have to make the soup
with the help of the pizza and then we
would eat it and we'd go like the holes
and do it and then I think we would um
it was one thing we had to do where like
God I don't know I have such a vivid
memory of this I think in some parts
they would um I think like Christmas or
something I can't remember when you
would do this
we spent like an hour just you had an
orange and you would just put clothes
like clothes into it I like the really
smelly things what are they are they
called they called cloves right oh
cloves yeah yeah
very aromatic things yeah literally just
stabbing Orange full of these and they'd
be like it would make the room smell
nice I don't know why but that's what we
did and that's how conagra's hate
towards orange juice
we did a few other things we didn't
really do anything like super cool like
I remember they would like show us where
they would train but they wouldn't let
us like touch anything honestly because
why would you let a five roll touch a
sword no that would have been badass
yeah I think it was pretty cool though
yeah I think like again like I I
wouldn't mind guided tours and stuff
like that if again there was that some
level of interactivity right because
like again it's like as a kid or even as
an adult if you just [ __ ] stand
around and look at something while a
person explains to you being like use
your imagination to imagine what it was
like what it looked like a thousand
years ago then it's like okay you know
history Buffs will be like Oh okay
that's kind of rad I'm standing on a
piece of history but to the average
person you'd just be like it's [ __ ]
field in it yeah like what what what am
I supposed to do with this information
it's like oh I'm sick all right like
it's it's it's always like even as an
adult that's why I don't really go to a
lot of like touristy places because you
know if if you tell if you tell me if
you tell me something happens there and
even if I go to the place it doesn't
like help me immerse myself in it yes I
actually like find a way to get myself
yeah unless you find a way to get me
can't to care about what's being said
you know unless someone's actually
passionate about it you know I've been
to [ __ ] Stonehenge it's fun it's a
bunch of [ __ ] rocks
it's a bunch of [ __ ] rocks okay you
could you could tell me that this was
the most historical site of like the
earliest side of man it's a bunch of
[ __ ] rocks okay was the most
disappointing thing I've ever seen in
your life I couldn't [ __ ] believe it
well we British like to disappoint like
it was like it looked better from the
highway yeah like then it does up close
I'm like wow that's a that's a first
yeah I look at like the Great Pyramids
of Giza I'm like that's a [ __ ] sight
man that's a story like that that is
somewhere I want to [ __ ] actually go
to and check out and then if you look at
what are you like Mom we have a
historical side at home and that's the
historical side we have the pyramids
have you seen like videos like at the
pyramids it's like there's so much trash
oh yeah so much like and there's like uh
not scalpers um people hackling you
trying to sell you stuff yeah it's just
like okay it's like that's when you're
like wow I feel like a tourist yeah I
think that's a problem right when you
when you get when you're made to feel
like you are just a cog in a moving pot
it doesn't feel genuine like it feels
like okay you're here for my money and
I'm leaving yeah not that any place has
owes you to make you feel like you
matter in any capacity but like when you
when you feel like you're there and
you're Chicago and disposable it feels
weird like if you think that's why
Disney has done so well like it's their
credit they make they try and make it
feel all like people who are into it
like you are like you're in Disney yeah
you are not we welcome you with open
arms everyone's so nice to you right
it's all it's all perfect right it's all
like choreographed perfectly I think
that's why people like it so well
because when you go to Disney like a lot
of people feel like they're you know
that it's a part of them like it's like
a real real connection they have to it
and the Disney World and land just helps
perpetuate that yeah for sure whereas
when you go to like [ __ ] Venice
you're like Jesus Christ this is awful I
can't wait to leave it's like oh I I
can't believe I'm looking at the
Coliseum like seven people are trying to
say right I I love this I can't wait to
buy a coffee for 15 [ __ ] Euros yeah
it tastes like [ __ ] it's like just just
just immerse yourself in the history it
says like 20 people taking selfies
behind oh yeah so many tourists Chinese
tourists just shouting at the top of
their lungs and it's just like I can't
immerse myself in this